c'est terminé pour kepler ce petit bijou
d'ingénierie spatiale qui a changé notre
façon de voir l'univers son réservoir de
carburant un vide ces instruments sont
éteints il poursuit maintenant seul
salon course auto du soleil texte mise
en orbite en 2009 on comptait sur kepler
pour identifier le grand nombre de
nouvelles planètes c'est mission
accomplie
tec est la robe de trois planètes et
3015 date
donc c'est au delà de nos espérances
mais surtout le télescope a découvert
plusieurs cousine de la terre d'autres
qui sont presque des jumelles
quel père le monde qu'il ya beaucoup d
opéra d'habitat beaucoup de l'important
est aussi des planètes qui sont prêts à
curieuse par rapport à notre point de
vue des rocheuses des gazeuses des
systèmes à deux soleils d'autres où liz
est sont synchronisées les instruments
extrêmement précis de mesure de la
lumière de kepler nous ont fait voyager
d'un monde étrange à l'autre la méthode
aussi est vraiment exceptionnel parce
qu'elle permet de remonter au rayon de
la planète ça c'est fondamental
c'est en connaissant le rayon et en
connaissant la masse par une autre
méthode on peut déterminer la densité
donc savoir s'il l'exoplanète est une
exoplanète plutôt de type rocheuse comme
la terre ou plutôt de type gazeuses
comme jupiter
aujourd'hui c'est la sonde test lancé en
avril dernier qui prend sa relève
tess va observer beaucoup plus près mais
il va observer tout le ciel et à ce
moment là on espère trouver aussi
beaucoup plus de d'objets plus semblable
en fait à à la terre au final qu'est
plein nous aura appris qu'il y a plus de
planètes que des toiles dans notre
galaxie et qu'au moins le quart d'entre
elles pourraient être des monde
habitable
pas mal pour un petit instrument dont le
réservoir comptait à peine 12 kg de
carburant au départ ici normand grondin
radio canada montréal